our next topic is multi-class
classifiers
so this refers to the situation where
the labels
which are the possible values of your
outcome
y instead of just having two values it
can have k values where k
is bigger than two um and those are
called either the labels or
i think sometimes in statistics these
are referred to as levels so you'd say
k levels i don't know this is just local
these are just local dialects
and we're going to assume that the label
set is going to be just the integers 1
through k
so we would refer to these as label or
classes so you'd say class
3 means whatever it could mean elephant
could mean orange
could mean fraud i don't know um
class seven means something like it
could mean
tuesday or i don't know uh
doesn't matter right so that's the idea
so we're talking about a case where
instead
of just guessing yes or no true or false
fraud not fraud this kind of thing
you're actually it's more nuanced and
you're actually making a guess among
several more than two choices
okay so now a predictor is going to be a
function
f hat that maps from rn
so it takes in the feature values that's
the vector x and
returns um actually just one of the
numbers like
3 or 7 or capital k or one
um and by the way this corresponds to by
the way to a partition
of the feature space because you can
imagine you can simply imagine the sets
of points
which are assigned to one of these
values that'll be some region and so
some people refer to this as the
predictor being a
it partitions the feature space into the
place where you make the different
guesses
okay now if i have a given predictor f
hat
and a data set my confusion matrix is
now
k by k it's not two by two as in the
boolean case
um and in this case uh we'll we'll get
to what that is but it's a bit it's just
a bit more complicated
and of course in in a lot of
applications you know
some of these off-diagonal entries may
be much worse than others
right so that that's actually one of the
things that would come up
okay so what are some examples of
multi-class classification well here's
an obvious one is
is just handwritten digit classification
so basically
i give you an image of a digit and uh
you're you have to guess zero through
nine so that's ten that's capital k
equals ten um remember in our last
example we were simply trying to guess
whether the given digit was a zero
or not a zero meaning one two three up
to nine
here's one marketing demographic
classification
so we would have our you know some
standard demographic groups let's say 60
of them
and what i would do is i would look at
some
purchase history uh or some other data
about a
a customer or a person and then i would
i would guess i'd say i my guess is they
are in group 12 and you know that means
something
right okay disease diagnosis when
there's more
that when you're doing more than just
trying to say is is this one disease
present
or not um so you would have a bunch of
candidate diseases
um oh including usually if you know one
one label is simply there's no disease
right so
um and here x uh the feature vector
would include test results uh
it would encode the symptoms of the
patient maybe some history of the
patients
maybe even some of their past treatments
this kind of thing
so that would be and from that you'd
look at it and say
why think this is disease a or this is
disease b
or this is the variant this is a variant
of disease b or this is or no disease i
think it's i think i think the patient
is fine
okay um another one would be translation
word choice
so um here uh
you have a dictionary uh you have
dictionary in english and you have a
dictionary in farsi or something like
that and so
you know it's easy enough to kind of
generate
uh with it but there's ambiguities right
so there's a word in english
that actually might have you know
whatever several different possible
words
it's ambiguous um in english
in farsi it's not it's like one of these
four or five words
and so what you could do is given the
context of that like the rest of the
english paragraph
say you could try to figure out which is
the right
word right so one example might be the
word
bank right so in english that could mean
the bank of a river
or a bank where money is right or it
could be to bank an airplane
um could be you know could mean a couple
of things um
these could be different in another
language in fact in many languages
these are different words and so your
job in translating is not to
is not to simply replace bank with one
of these definitions but you have to
kind of figure out which it is
and so this would be a perfect example
of a multi-class
well if there's only two choices it's
boolean or binary
but in general there would be several
choices and it's your job to try to
figure out which it is
and you could look through the rest of
the paragraph that's the context that
would be x
and you might either you might find
words about banking regulators blah blah
blah this kind of stuff you know money
exchange rates
and then you'd guess okay by bank they
don't mean bank an airplane and they
don't mean the bank of a river it means
a bank
where money is okay financial
institution right so something like that
let's give an example um document topic
prediction
so this would be you'd have new uh new
documents or
a a a a cache of documents a set of
documents a corpus people would say
of documents and you a new document
enters the corpus uh could be a new
wikipedia page i mean it doesn't matter
right
and your job is to assign it to one of
like you know 37 different topics
is it sports is it politics is it
science
you know i don't know i mean it's one of
these right and that would be the ideas
you you would make a guess as to which
is based on some features of it could be
word count
uh histogram for example right so that
would be an example of
that's document topic prediction
okay so let me explain how to a way to
do this
as with a boolean classification
you will learn you know different and
more sophisticated and
honestly better methods to do least
squares
uh sorry to do multi-class
classification um
but the least squares one is not so bad
and it introduces some ideas that will
be useful
and so on and it just uses the stuff we
have in the class so far
so having said that though um let me
explain how
how you could do it using uh using least
squares
okay so uh this very simple method what
you do is you
you create a least squares classifier
for each label versus the others
okay so if if in fact your
your labels are you know apple uh
banana right and peach
right um and you're given let's say an
image or i
it doesn't matter right then uh what you
do is you
just like we did with the digits the
mnist digits we would build a classifier
that tries to predict whether it's an
apple versus a but a banana or peach we
would build a second classifier that
attempts to say
whether it's whether it's a banana
versus an apple or a peach and then
finally one that
attempts to say is it a peach versus an
apple or a banana
okay so you build three classifiers one
separately for each of the labels
which attempts to detect that label
versus the others um
so that's that that's how uh that that's
how that would
would work by the way there's several
things you could do then
one is is actually to do things like uh
well okay i'll say that the the way that
works best with
least squares goes like this we actually
don't use the hats
we use the tildes now remember that
f hat is either minus one or plus one so
f hat equals plus one so f
two hat of x equals minus one
means i don't think it's a banana i
think it's an apple or a peach
that's what it means okay but we'll
actually work with the precursor of
f hat two we're going to work with f
tilde of x
equals minus 0.1 okay
now there's a lot more nuance in here
because
if this were like minus minus one or
minus point nine
we would have said well we don't that's
definitely not
uh that is that is not an apple or a
peach and we're pretty certain
but minus point one means you're like
could you know could be i mean if you
force me to make a decision
is it a p is it a banana or an apple or
a peach it
you know if you force me to i'm gonna
say it's it's not a
it is not a banana but you know
this says that your confidence is not
high so what we're going to do
is we're going to evaluate that that
number the the precursor to the actual
prediction
um for each of the different classes um
and then
i have to explain this notation argmax
so
the okay you know what the maximum of a
set of numbers is right
so the max of a1 a2 a3 is just the
largest of the numbers
okay and it's a number arcmax gives you
the
index of whoever is the largest right
and by the way if there's multiple that
detain the largest then it's not you
just choose one it doesn't matter which
one
okay so what this says is super
interesting it says
you query for each label you query your
classifier and you get f tilde
sub l right that's a number right if
it's like really close to one
it means you it means that thing is
really confident that
that it's that that the thing you're
looking at is class l
um if it's really close to minus one
that thing is really confident
it's not okay but you know if it's 0.3
it means
maybe i don't know if it's minus you
know 0.6 it's somewhere in between and
all that
so what this does is it simply says look
at the one
that has the highest if we think of f
tilde as being sort of the confidence
in our guess that it's positive this is
find not just the one that's positive
but the one that has the highest
confidence in being positive
right and that's that's that's what this
says that's how you that's how you guess
it
so for example if i have an x and f one
tilde
is minus point seven uh f utility is
plus point two and f three
of x tilde is plus point eight well
first let's analyze that before we make
a decision
and we'll use these labels up here so
the first one
says says that if you pose the question
is this an apple or is it possibly a
banana or a peach
this says i don't think it's an apple
i'm pretty
and it's pretty certain it's basically
saying you know pretty confident saying
like it's
not an apple so okay that means probably
it's a banana
or a peach okay this one
is interesting that says that if i ask
you is it a banana
versus is it an apple or a peach it's
basically saying
maybe yeah maybe it's a banana sure
maybe it is a banana i don't know
um and then you say well how confident
are you and you say well a bit
a bit confident not not horribly
confident but but but
a bit confident that's what the point
two means
then we go to f3 till the of x which is
plus point eight now the meaning of that
is
we've queried our classifier and we've
asked for this x
does it represent a peach or is it an
apple or banana
and this thing says oh that's a peach
that's what that's a point eight means
it's a high number
of course when you take the sign of it
you would get you you would get you know
f hat
three is is plus one
f hat two is plus one and
f hat one is is going to be
minus one right so i mean
that that's why this doesn't give you
enough information to really make a good
guess right i mean you can guess it's
not an apple but it's
you don't know if it's a banana or a
peach so what we've really done is we've
gone with the guests
which is most we have the highest
confidence in
and so that's actually going to be peach
in this case so we take f
of x is this right and so this is the
idea it's relatively simple
um and you know it actually doesn't
work too badly like at all so
here's what happens if we run this on
handwritten digit
classification right so we have 10
classes and this is our confusion matrix
which is
you know 10 by 10 right and so this is
the you know i mean we could look at
this like that is the number
out of ten thousand this is the test set
so in our test set
there were digits that were really a
three that we thought were a one
and there were 18 of them that's what
that means so here here's one where we
did pretty good
zero there were in our test set
there were absolutely no times that
something was a six and we thought it
was a three
so the diagonal here these are
well not that diagonal there we go these
here those are the ones where we did it
right
right so that's cool everything off the
diagonal all the numbers are bad
now let's look for some of the work
let's see where we did the worst
um or let's see let's let's find some
places where we did badly if not the
worst here you go
that's bad okay 80. and so let's see
what that's about
well that's a time when the digit was a
nine
but we guessed the four now that's
completely that makes perfect sense by
the way you know
humans would make that mistake too right
there'd be a lot of times when it's a
nine but
but um it's really a four uh so that
kind of makes sense i mean these things
make sense if you look at some others
where we did poorly
it would be oh confusing a nine and a
seven
i know lots of people who make nines and
sevens that look pretty similar so again
that's kind of reasonable
so this is it the error rate is around
and and it's not over fit because on the
training set you get about the same
that's actually pretty bad that means
that basically one in six
times our our this thing you know
basically makes an error on the digit
um that's but on the other hand this is
just
this is the simplest possible model it's
a regression model basically we haven't
and which is
you know not even really appropriate but
it's kind of cool that you get even
like five that you get that your your
error rate is only 14
that's a pretty good starting point you
can't do uh worse you know can't do much
worse than that
sorry yeah it means that's a good
way to start we'll we'll only do better
okay and so i'll show you just one very
simple thing
um it's a it's a crazy thing uh it's you
know relatively
new research or whatever but i'll show
you what it is um
mostly people think of feature
engineering is done in a very
uh thoughtful and mindful way like you
would you go to an expert and they go
well i think you should have the product
of these features because there's some
interaction you like cool and then you
add these features and
of course you don't do it because the
expert
you do it because well you take the
advice of the expert but then what you
do is everything what matters is
the only that matters is the test
performance right so how does it work on
data it's never seen
so here though uh there's this is
something that's come up five ten years
ago
we're gonna make random features so
here's here's what we do we're gonna
take
5 000 uh new completely random features
we're going to generate a random 5000 by
494 matrix
um and the entries are plus minus one
that's it just
we flip a coin and we fill out this
matrix
then we form our x uh sub j and zero
the backs of it right so this is crazy
it is utterly uninterpretable it means
absolutely nothing
uh it's very much like um actually a
neural network which is something you
may have heard about and
you certainly will hear about in other
courses
okay so that's just random features and
now instead of 494 features we've got
5494 features
okay now when you do this
you get a training set error that's
about 1.5 and a test error that's 2.6
and you can do better if i mean if you
start crafting weird new features
not weird new features but features that
are actually that kind of make sense uh
you
can do better and um the current
state of the art is like it's it's like
almost perfect um
in fact the current state of the art uh
is that
these things can be recognized better
than people um
which kind of weird you might ask like
what does that even mean um
they do have a way of checking the
ground truth right that if you for
example
suppose people say no dude that's a nine
and this thing says that's a seven then
the way you can resolve that of course
is that is by context these could be zip
codes and one
one could not make sense and the other
does make sense and stuff like that but
nevertheless
it's it's very cool um and by the way at
this point in the course i mean what it
does is it shows you that this just
demystifies a lot of these things i mean
if you didn't know about the stuff you
know in this course so
far i i don't even know
how you would think that's done i mean
how does a camera look at a
handwritten thing and tell you what it
is
um you know and now you know at least
some of the
the the uh methods used um
people don't use least squares but they
use things that are very very close to
least squares and in spirit it's very
similar
um and you know honestly it's a secret
uh don't tell other people but it's not
that complicated
right i mean least squares is just it's
just not that complicated but uh you
know
again don't tell people because it makes
us look uh
impressive uh if to if most people don't
know how this stuff works and that it's
not really as complicated as it looks
it keeps our salaries high and things
like that so again
if you're among friends yeah you can say
sure it's not that
not that big a deal uh but i'm asking
you now just for all of us collectively
please don't explain
to a lot of to too many people that
these things are not as
they're really just not as hard as they
look
good so when you add the new features
here's what happens
um well okay first of all your eyeball
looking at that confusion matrix tells
you you're doing pretty good
um i mean you have 10 000
data points and take a look at this i
mean
the number of errors you're making are
numbers like zero
one three i mean that's pretty good if
you ask me that's
it's looking pretty good um now you're
still having some trouble here
right here are some here once you're
making a mistake you know you're
mistaking a seven and a two
you know 12 times so but this is this is
pretty good
uh and it's it's pretty impressive and
like i said this was just adding these
5000 random features so
if you actually add features in an
intelligent way and stuff like that
you can you can get you can get this
down to all small digits like zeros ones
and i believe
the current state of the art on test set
just
zero flat zero that's on this test set
just it's zero
right on on bigger tests you have to
have a bigger test set to actually
detect
uh any failure of sort of
state-of-the-art methods right now
you